oh go ahead girl take it all in
cindy sweeney cries tears of joy after
learning she scored two emmy nominations
for two separate performances
thanks mom
the 24 year old is nominated for
outstanding supporting actress in a
drama series for her role as cassie on
euphoria you guys can all judge me if
you want but i do not care i have never
ever been happier and she also nabbed a
nom in the supporting actress category
for her character olivia and the white
lotus which is up for outstanding
limited series you gave him the codes
who are safe
paula do you think i'm some sort of
idiot and i'm so terrified of olivia so
it's really fun
playing a character that you're scared
of along with sharing her happy tears
while she calls her mom to bask in the
news sydney captions the post with this
heartfelt message writing in part quote
i'm so proud of both these shows and
grateful to everybody that's been a part
of them but most importantly mom i love
you we did it through the ups and downs
um hold on everyone i'll call you right
back someone cheering sydney on in the
comments is her euphoria co-star zendaya
who writes quote yes sid congratulations
i'm so lucky to be working with the
people that i'm working with and
speaking of zendaya she also has a lot
to celebrate right now as she makes
history once again the 25 year old who
won the emmy for outstanding lead
actress in a drama series for her role
as rue in euphoria in 2021 was
recognized again in the category making
her the youngest two-time lead acting
nominee it means so much to me meanwhile
it's also a big victory for team white
lotus as many of sydney's co-stars also
landed noms including first-time nominee
jennifer coolidge who was up for
outstanding supporting actress for her
role as troubled guest tanya mccoy you
think you could have dinner with me at
the hotel tonight um
i get off at seven yeah that's good i
mean like a couple minutes after seven
at the at the restaurant
sounds great that's the most popular
thing i think i've ever done where
people just came out of the woodwork and
murray bartlett who was nominated in the
supporting actor category for his
performance as a luxury hotel's manager
armand
watching them eat every night makes me
want to
gouge my eyes out while fans await the
official season to release date of the
hit hbo max drama here's what jennifer
coolidge told et last year about the
hopes and wishes she has for her
character i hope i have lots of
romance and sex in this next one
you know i felt like i didn't get enough
of that in the first one